[Musique]
un peu de réconfort pour des résidents
durement touchée montréal-nord quartiers
défavorisés et multiethnique est devenu
le secteur chaud de la pandémie au
canada s'est jamais kate avec peut-être
la réouverture des écoles faut faire
attention tout ce que le gouvernement
dément il faut le respecter par sana
d'argent non comme on devait vous aurez
à boucler des fins de mois donc de
protection
ça passe en second plan 85 mille
personnes vivent ici sur un territoire
de 11 kilomètres carrés
le confinement y est encore plus
difficile qu'ailleurs quand ils sortent
et arrive dans un quartier dense où il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont à
l'extérieur donc plus difficile de
respecter le 2 mai et en même pas qu'on
veut dans les parcs à montbernard
n'allait plus bas un deal de park sur
l'île l'arrondissement crée donc
plusieurs corridors sanitaire comme
celui-ci et va bientôt distribuer des
milliers de masques avec la santé
publique on augmentera aussi la
sensibilisation un grand besoin
moi j'essaie par damian à distance je
dois points mais il y en a qui disent
qu'ils ne savent pas c'est collé collé
collé vraiment collé il faut qu'on la
dise
prenez votre distance le deux miles
était partant mais là ça qu'on prenne à
rien ce sont des gens qui sont habitués
à se donner des défis habitués à voir
des maladies habitude héritée d'un des
pays que la vie n'est pas rose à tous
les jours ci que poté de ça dont qui est
on prend conscience de la problématique
et des caisses qui on doit faire un
petit peu plus tard autre facteur 253
travailleurs de la santé ont contracté
le virus dans montréal-nord beaucoup
plus que la moyenne montréalaise
l'arrondissement compte de nombreux
préposés aux bénéficiaires ou
d'infirmières auxiliaires comme brunilda
reyes jadis c'est un travail qui n'a pas
besoin de beaucoup de formation de vos
coudes et scolarité pour pouvoir aller
les faits on les fait beaucoup beaucoup
avec les choeurs et avec l'allemande et
vouloir et d'éléments sur place ce midi
plusieurs députés libéraux ont remis en
question le déconfinement qui s'en vient
dans l'arrondissement et même ailleurs à
montréal
l'impression qu'à montréal actuellement
on est en train de perdre le contrôle et
la seule façon de déconfinement
efficacement montréal s'est
véritablement d'augmenter de façon
significative les tests la santé
publique répond qu'une clinique de
dépistage sera bientôt installée dans le
quartier à montréal nord la bataille
contre le coronavirus ne fait que
commencer ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal